well taking the mound tonight for the
tampa bay rays right-hander charlie
morton looking for his first win of the
season
and a cut and a miss out of fastball in
94.
that's something we might watch tonight
about to raise right-hander charlie
morton
and a line drive caught by choi
a one two three first native all he want
to know 245 the earned run average well
he's done his job two good starts for
the red sox throwing all of his pitches
looked good so far austin is indeed back
after a stint on the covet 19 injured
list
3-2 again
made a great pitch on the outside corner
meadows right through it strikeout
number one that'll send up brandon lau
the second baseman
one man now no score first inning
and he went down after that chased it
and down he goes both sides move quickly
and quietly done with one no score so
one out and the base is empty for mitch
moreland
high fly ball
that one driven to right that's deep
backing up renfro at the wall leaping
can't get it it is gone and the red sox
have the lead i wasn't sure he got
enough of that but up in the air like
that he'll take it well just sort of
brush the back wall normally there's no
doubters when moreland gets into one
one nothing boston three and two the
count to suzugo and he swings and misses
at 96.
strikeout number three for nate so
here's joey wendell
back into deep center straight away
bradley goes back it's gonna be over his
head off the wall wendell's gonna dig
for three
he will make it easily
three bases for joey wendell we found it
the whole way and just over that glove
on a red for a 180 2-2 home run
oh
man 97 on the black good luck
he struck out two in the inning and they
freeze the runner at third two out
nobody on it leaves it for austin
meadows
and there's a base hit through the left
side just to the right of bogarts over
to make the pickup meadows has his first
hit go ahead run us at the plate now and
brandon low
reaches out flies that one jackie on the
move he dives did he make the play he
caught the ball
jackie bradley jr now they're saying he
didn't is the throw to the plate
and the run is going to come on in to
score he thinks he caught it and they
said he trapped it
oh he got it oh yeah he's got it that's
why he's running to the dugout yes
but here's the answer and out thank you
joe thank you very much joe jackie
bradley makes a great catch for out
number three red sox still leading one
to nothing
so that'll put two on for renfro
all right pop up by renfro
foul ball
endeavors that ball wound up that's a
foul ball throw to fergus safe there
we're not i'm not sure if that ball hit
fair or foul coming down debra's went
over
where he thought it was going to be you
know that's the thing if it hits the one
of the the beans up there or the rings
in foul territory then it's a foul ball
so that will go as a foul ball
now a fly ball right center field
bradley on the run can't get there he'll
chase it all the way to the wall
zazugo scores wendell will score it's a
double for renfro and the raids will
take a 2-1 lead
the rays have a 2-1 lead michael perez
and perez is headed by that first pitch
and he is in instant pain right there
he doesn't want to come out of the
lineup
first in the fifth austin meadows at the
plate he sends a fly ball back into
right field that's got some carry and
it's going to be over the head of her do
going off the wall
perez will hit third nanaris will wave
him home heading to third
and the rays have a 3-1 lead and here's
brandon lau with the infield up
a long shot by lau
back into right one hop cut off by
verdugo
meadows scores loud drives him home
ninth rbi for lau
and the rays put up
a couple more runs here in the fifth to
make it four to one
and a swing and a miss
big big strikeout there of a dangerous
hitter how about the acknowledgement
from zander bogarts he swung and missed
that pitch and then pointed out at
charlie like you got me
so another opportunity for the rays
g-man choi facing the right-hander
brazier
eyeball back to left ben and tendy there
to catch it the tag
at third and lau will score and the rays
have
another run
5-1 raise and it's getting a little
shaky here two men on and a 1-1 home to
jackie
high chop on the infield
wendell will fire on to first and safe
red sox have a heartbeat in the ninth
inning the bases are loaded one down
jose with a base hit in the third
and he's got one now strike called on
the outside corner for out number two if
ben attendee is gonna break out this
would be the time
oh there it is he came back with a
breaking ball strength recalled on the
curve and this game is over